benjamin lucas bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
c'était l'une des mesures phares de
benoît mans lors de la campagne
présidentielle de 2010 est la création
d'un revenu universel pour tous sans
condition une idée qui refait surface
aujourd'hui pourquoi mais parce qu'on le
voit la crise que nous vivons est le
balaye les certitudes du monde des
certitudes du monde libéral qui par
exemple considère qu'on est payé en
fonction de la valeur que le marché nous
donne on voit que c'est juste pour le
marché c'est pas juste pour la société
puisque aujourd'hui n'est pas
nécessairement de corrélation entre
votre utilité sociale et votre salaire
je pense aux infirmières aux éboueurs et
c'est à tous ceux qui permettent au pays
d'avoir la tête hors de l'eau pendant
cette épidémie on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui leur rémunération ne
correspond pas à leur utilité
et puis même le travail a buté le monde
évolue sous nos yeux tout le monde
s'accorde à dire que le monde d'après
même le président de la république c'est
dire que le monde d'après ne pourra pas
ressembler au monde d'avant donc il faut
apporter des solutions nouvelles
innovantes et audacieuses
nous avions commencé à travailler au
sujet du revenu universel à l'occasion
de la campagne présidentielle de 2017
aujourd'hui il s'impose à la fois comme
une réponse aux urgences de la crise aux
urgences quotidiennes de nos concitoyens
dont beaucoup cherchent à à survivre à
joindre les deux bouts chercha à passer
le cap de cette crise et puis il est
aussi une réponse aux colossaux défis de
l'avenir pour faire un choc de
répartition de partage pour repenser
notre rapport au travail pour faire des
citoyens des acteurs des transformations
nécessaires de la société alors c'est
une idée qui ne provient pas seulement
de la gauche française le royaume uni
l'allemagne l'espagne ou encore les
etats-unis exhortent les gouvernement
d'introduire un revenu de base universel
mais en quoi cette idée pourrait
vraiment répondre à la crise actuelle
que nous traversons bien d'abord parce
qu'elle garantirait à chacune et à
chacun un revenu pour vivre pour se
nourrir pour nourrir sa famille pour
pour continuer finalement à vivre dans
des conditions de dignité c'est en ça
que c'est une réponse urgente et
nécessaire parce qu'on voit par exemple
au chômage partiel il ya plein de gens
qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas protégés par
le chômage partiel qui ne concerne que
les salariés qui sont pas salariés et
vous en avez aussi qui qui s'engagent et
qui font d'autres choses
bien qu'aujourd'hui c'est une réponse à
la fois cette urgence a pu ensuite c'est
un filet de protection c'est un nouveau
pilier de la protection sociale et donc
qu'est ce qui nous dit que des crises
comme ça n'arriveront plus demain qui
avait prévu cette crise aujourd'hui il
faut aujourd'hui être en capacité de se
dire que dans les crises que nous allons
vivre nous pouvons vivre dans les années
dans les décennies à venir
il faut des outils qui permettent de
protéger nos concitoyens je pense que le
revenu universel en études importantes
majeure et essentielle selon vous est ce
que cette idée pourrait également
permettre de réduire les inégalités
sociales
bien sûr le revenu universel d'existence
c'est l'outil le plus efficace à notre
avis pour éradiquer la pauvreté pour
garantir la dignité pour offrir à la
jeunesse les conditions de son autonomie
aujourd'hui par exemple beaucoup trop de
jeunes sont obligés de se salarier en
même temps qu'ils font leurs études et
échoue dans l'enseignement supérieur
parce que ils n'ont pas tout simplement
les moyens d'étudier dans de bonnes
conditions et correctement dans qu'on
voit à chaque âge de la vie pour chaque
domaine revenu universel il est une
protection essentielle est un instrument
de lutte contre les inégalités je crois
que c'est un objectif prioritaire dans
notre société on l'a vu là encore avec
cette crise mais un revenu universel qui
serait versée justement à chaque citoyen
est ce qu y at-il un risque concernant
l'augmentation de la pression fiscale on
sait qu'elle est déjà bien impactés par
cette crise du cora d'un virus je crois
qu'il faut pas raisonner avec les
paradigmes les dogmes les réflexes du
duché monde il faudra repenser notre
fiscalité la rendre plus juste
on n'a pas fait depuis des décennies
dans l'eau dans nos sociétés le choc de
répartition du partage nécessaire
les inégalités se creusent alors que la
richesse augmenter de plus en plus
concentré il faut donc répartir partager
nous ne pensons qu'il faut partager
partager les ressources et la transition
écologique partager les richesses pour
la justice sociale et la dignité
partager les pouvoirs aussi c'est
l'aspiration à une démocratie plus plus
apaisée avec un nouveau souffle donc on
le voit il faudra réfléchir repenser
autrement aussi notre notre fiscalité
mais encore une fois comme c'est un
revenu universel d'existence
je crois que ce sera aussi un moyen de
retrouver une barre de pouvoir par part
notamment un revenu inconditionnel
universelle versée à qui vous avez tous
très bien merci beaucoup benjamins lucas
porte parole du mouvement générations
est d'avoir répondu à nos questions